hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm standing in newcastle right now
and the average cost of a house around
here they're around about 80
90 000 pounds for these houses however
there was a pub for sale now this pub
was
snapped up by my mum ryan what's
happening ryan how you doing
ryan bought this pub how much for 130
grand 130 grand
now he's just refurbished it he's pushed
the value split the titles
what's the current value of the pub 700
700 thousand pounds
serious serious so you made like quarter
of a million pounds profit
let's go around i want you to show us
the figures and you'll see exactly how
he did this commercial to residential
pub conversion let's go
what how bad was this what was the
condition oh this was like derelict
derelict finished empty for about two
years
you've turned this place busy roads you
can hear that
you can hear the high street traffic so
you've turned this into hmo yeah
so it's very nice so how much will these
rooms run out for these will rent for
four to four to five maybe even 450
instead of the bigger rooms
okay so about four four fifty per room
and you've got an eight bed hmo
plus plus oh wow these are nice
these are nice plus you've got a uh
an apartment and another apartment and
another apartment and another apartment
and another apartment yeah
it's got a whole bunch of apartments
eight bed hmo
so talk me through how you found it how
you calculated it yeah and what made you
buy it
how did you know it's gonna value up
well we knew because of
uh seeing a lot of your videos and
seeing of speak to the right amount of
people that if you buy commercial
convert to resi you can uplift value
a lot more than a standard house yeah
and obviously the auction price was so
cheap for how big it was we were just
like this would be silly not to get this
like surely there's a scheme here that
we can do and we had to because it was
auction condition conditions were to be
very quick about our
feasibility studies but figured you
could definitely get a good size hmo and
a few flats here
yeah and then so when you bought it you
didn't have any planning permission
no no how did you know you were gonna
get planning uh
spoke to the a lot of locals uh local
builders local project managers
and uh they were like yeah any day
they'll get planning for that and we
were like
cool here's the thing right of course
you're gonna get planned because the
council
don't want derrick pop sitting around
they attract the wrong people of course
they do so so the council are desperate
to get these old pubs converted
also these old pubs commercial
properties are valued
based on their rent if they're derelict
there is no rent
yeah commercial property commercial
property the prices are dropping and
dropping and dropping because of the
pandemic
residential property's going up so
you bought it bang converted into a
residential
um eight eight hmo rooms and five
apartments
and that's worth 700 grand you must be
gasped when you've got that evaluation
yes yeah it was like
all money out like because we had so
many problems with because coronavirus
we just thought like you know how many
more mistakes can keep can keep
potentially going wrong
and then when you've got the value and
you also you used your own money for
this project
yeah well you and your dad teamed up
yeah you're 25
yeah to make quarter million pounds at
25. and because you've done it
you're now pulling other investors into
your other projects you've got another
one the same as this
yeah another two like this they're
literally like this
one is bigger but you've bought uh
secured
so yeah so like but the important
subject to planning so come on we've got
we've got this guy knows what he's doing
he's going to be a next multi multi
multi multi freaking millionaire keep
showing me around bro i'm so gassed yes
i'm after you so that's that's one of
the smaller rooms
we can't go in every room no we went in
every room this video will be a 45
minute video
but just to give you a bit of a lowdown
where's the kitchen at well it's kitchen
there your bedroom there bedrooms that
way
look how big it is it's like a maze
another bedroom and the apartments are
all off they've got a different entrance
to them
yeah absolutely awesome multiple
bathrooms
multiple things going on streets all
along streets whole different separate
part of the building whether whether
yeah
where the where the planting machine is
so how do you get flying permission then
what do you have to do to get planning
you have to run well i mean there's all
the back end stuff like running your
feasibility knowing that what you're
submitting for is going to make
financial sense for us as a business
and then an investment but to actually
go for the planning procedure you need
an architect
you need to meet certain compliance you
need to anticipate fire eggs and certain
other things but then it is literally
just submit to the council they'll open
an online portal just email them the
plans
and just go hey i'm looking at building
this these are the plans yes they say
yes
then you say to the builders this is the
plans knock yourself out yeah well
in this case they had a few comments but
there was nothing like a note it was
just
actually we want you to consider this
consider that consider a fire escape
like this
the kitchen was actually the problem in
this one we thought our scheme initially
was better but they um was a bigger
kitchen
but now there's a smaller kitchen but
it's got the exit which is what they've
got two entrances with what they wanted
uh that was the only pushback we had
though when you said to the builder here
the plans go knock yourself out
the builder literally did the project
manager yeah sorry i thought you meant
that because the builder is quite happy
in this one um
right yeah so when we started our
project manager unfortunately
uh had a bad accident or someone mugged
him um
the dude out yeah on our first project
yeah you got people
knocking you out jeez it meant that he
was
he was he was essentially i don't know
because it's his life this is his
private thing but essentially
he was out of action for a while whilst
we were starting the refurb and going
into corona
um and we had no project manager our
builder stepped
up and did us bits and for that i'm
eternally grateful
yeah uh and um it meant that we're to
what
what do you think of this area do you
think this area is bad
do you think it's not buying in this
area yeah go on now
you're from london yeah yeah i'm from
would you say to someone from london
that just says
and to be fair you have a lot of crime
in london anyway but someone in london
this is newcastle right someone in
london that might say
i just want to buy in london only yeah
what would you say
if your motive is to make money then i
i mean if you want to do nothing you
could just park your money in london and
do nothing
in 10 years it will double london goes
up like crazy but i mean if you really
want to make
some cash flow and make some good money
just stupid and not go north
because the rent for these rooms and for
these flats
are not much different from london yeah
they're the same in some it's like you
can get 550 hmo rooms in newcastle yeah
and you
i know someone who's got 450 hmo room in
london so the rents are almost the same
in some instances
but you bought the entire building for
130 grand
exactly absolutely crazy
so how do you because one of the things
the couple of things that i always say
which i think you've proven to be true
one thing is
a big deal takes just as much effort as
a small deal because this has been
pretty hands-off for you
yeah i mean you've come down you've been
help helping oversee it but
i know you spent less time on this than
you do on some of your small projects
um second thing is power of momentum
yeah
you only got started doing this 18
months ago yeah yeah
i remember sitting out having dinner
with you you told me you went to do rent
to rent
yeah yeah i was like you don't want to
do rent to rent bro you do really big
things with music
got a massive following you need to be
doing some big projects
proving you can do it learning on the
job getting a really good power team and
then you need to be bringing in
investors
and growing big and that's what you're
doing now yeah you've got some big stuff
going on that's
literally that there's so much hassle
with i mean there's been hassles with
this don't get me wrong but the reward
is so much better that
i would take castles with this any day
compared to an hmo i just i just can't
see myself ever doing hmo again like a
seven eight nine bed hmo
slightly different yeah bigger if it's a
good deal then that works out nicely
because you can look at
pocketing fifteen hundred two grand a
month from now but i just would never do
a smaller deal again why make 250 quid a
month from a buy to let when you can
make 250
000 pounds profit in the space of eight
nine months on a pub conversion
massively
commercial to residential everybody
wants to focus on the pennies but
they're so focused on the pennies that
they missed a million
yeah yeah that's the big picture right
they missed a big picture so
okay so commercial to residential
however i don't want to misguide anybody
i personally have to say i bet you'd
agree with me don't jump straight to a
project like this
okay without first having some
experience having some training
having some support uh i don't know
would you agree yeah absolutely yeah
like it this
it's done like this was one of the first
thing we bought um
but we did run in tandem a five bed hmo
which taught us some lessons that we
adapted here we got we you know but
because we tried to try stuff if we
didn't try it we wouldn't have learned
you're gonna mess up when you start so
you may as well mess up on small deals
yeah
make the mistakes on small deals grow to
big deals but ultimately a big deal a
small deal take just as much effort yeah
and
if you've got the balls big deal yeah if
you've got the balls
it's going to it's going to take exactly
the same amount so figures figures i
can't i can't quite believe that figures
man yes
this is serious some serious figures
bought it for 130 spent
240 doing it up 370 all in
plus a bit a few of bits and bobs so
you're calling stamp duty and
professional fees
all all in 450 yeah say that yeah 700
grand
is the new value minus 450 is leaving
you oh sugar
i did that one wrong 700 grams minus 450
is gonna leave you with a nice clean
quarter of
a million pounds that's 35 net a year
and 35 000 pounds clean profit a year
you want to do big deals like this learn
like ryan did
start on small deals get educated this
this guy just messaged me a couple years
ago i was like dude take me out for
dinner
or let me buy you lunch you know but
that's the thing though that's the
difference between a go
app someone's prepared to be like you're
doing well come on let's have lunch
and i bet you've done that with lots of
different people with builders and
architects and
yeah just getting your team around this
guy will jump
on a in a car drive five hours
to newcastle just to view a potential
house and then drive back to london
if you're prepared to do what most
people are not prepared to do you're
going to live the life most people can
never live
yeah yeah absolutely so dude i'm i'm
well pleased with this project i'm well
pleased to be acquainted with yes
you want to see more projects like this
we've got some big stuff coming up
so don't forget to subscribe you can
subscribe right up here
you want to see more videos like this
you want to see me building six houses
from scratch making half a million pound
profit
you can check that video up here don't
forget to subscribe i'll see you guys
next time